hey how's it goin breasts my name is
Mira today is a very special day I have
in front of me
Walking Dead see that season three now
Walking Dead it's a very dear game
serious to my heart
I love season one I loved season two and
here we are with six and three finally
I'm really excited to see what's gonna
happen
Oh get the Walking Dead Michonne I think
No thank you that was garbage and if
season three is like that I'm gonna be
well [ __ ] pissed now the reason why
we all love Walking Dead is because kiss
a Clementine
okay greatest character of all all the
time maybe a little bit of an
exaggeration but we are invested in this
character okay and Kenny alright I care
about Kenny
because how many hours have we spent on
this you know I'm invested I think you
are as well if you're watching this and
if you do or not
check out season one right [ __ ] now
now we I know this okay so we get to
choose how we left the story of right
cuz choices matter no they [ __ ] don't
I start a new story Asha I already
[ __ ] them and [ __ ] ouch okay wait what
so episode 1 & 2 are already out what Oh
they'd never done that before
that's a strange move from telltale
let's give it a go I guess so we're
gonna continue our story recreate your
story oh we get to oh it's so cute
okay so we we we shot him after Lee's
deaf Klem found survivals people who
helped her such as Kenny
Clementine remember the joy she felt
with Kenny
it depended on family thanks to her
companions claims journey ultimately led
her to we let it let us to Wellington
that's standing I really like I think we
should enter Wellington I think that's a
more interesting
Clem learned the hard way to survive
depending on let's just start I am very
confused this seems like a lot of
difference changes huh okay interesting
there that's barely visible can't see it
oh I'm nervous I am very nervous okay
let me tell you baby you know in season
two I didn't have myself I either and
you had to replay the entirety of season
one but if she let me tell you is the
most boring thing you could possibly do
because there's no fast forward and
there's it you have to be careful it's
time already we [ __ ] up every time
every [ __ ] time okay every [ __ ]
time I swear to God show the [ __ ]
subtitles now you need to hurry look I'm
not giving you [ __ ] okay you weren't
here when dad was sick okay I get it but
this looks cool you need to [ __ ] be
here when he goes this is before
should happen I suppose the good all
this evil Americans David Haye sitting
on your front yard front porch drinking
hey David I had to leave my cards
traffic is backed up for miles
Oh it's as it's happening who's dead ooh
Willie turn perhaps why do I know I
don't know her no night I tried you're a
piece of [ __ ] you know that one time
just the one goddamn time that you
needed to be here I try to get here and
tried please I tried oh you tried you
[ __ ] try everyone's here they've been
here for days and where the [ __ ] were
you I was clearly running over there
all around him people who loved him all
around him and he's scared I'm seeing
the panic in his eyes and he's searching
the room though mr. Xavier let me stop
me huh
I'm there right beside him holding his
hand like a good son and he doesn't even
see me he doesn't even see me because
he's looking for you you don't think
there's a million places we'd rather be
you don't think we all had to make
sacrifices he was my dad too all right
you're not the only one dealing with
this and what a fine son you turned out
to be javi
what why are you fighting
oh my god it's potato boy I could hear
you from inside we were just talking
Gabriel right your uncle and I are just
having a little chat
with our fists go inside me home we'll
be in in a minute go where's clementines
okay inside yeah getting side potato boy
[ __ ] [ __ ]
potato [ __ ] potential boyfriend
material for a Clementine oh my god
sometimes you just gotta fight it out
and not be a little [ __ ] afterwards you
know I should call someone pick up the
body yeah
they they just I love you little brother
see they got it out of there you know
that right girls are just passive
aggressive in stand everything going on
well you got a pretty funny way of
showing it
well I think I was jealousy you know I
don't think anything now kiss well that
was for a long time you've lost more
than I'll ever have but maybe something
good can come out all this cuz we need
you here it's time to grow up
you can't run from this not anymore I
don't know I don't know I genuinely
don't know if the silence is the valley
not take some responsibility hobby cake
I'm so sorry javi I'm so sorry
thank you Spanish because they really
mean like is it just me what happened
yeah I fell on a ice skating range
come on
[Music]
so we play baseball
I'm sure we're gonna get a baseball bat
later as a weapon Wow
something's happening in the background
out of all this it seems like the
outbreak almost mama Oh were you at
someone hit me I tried I tried I'm so
sorry he's gone mijo
he's gone he's in a better place mama
you got that right telltale presence
that's a bit weird time to put in the
title I never understand when they do
that no puedo connector me do you think
in my service you
I like this because then we get to
experience the outbreak which I think
it's a very exciting part to to be
experiencing a thirsty baby and if you
want some juice
grandpa's cup was empty grandpa is dead
you just have to fill this cup up
anymore baby
grandpa's sleeping no yeah yeah he was
awake ah that's creepy
that's nice nice I like that you
probably should not be okay Jesus Oh sky
by know that this is their baby
they know they can't [ __ ] this one up
and it's going well so far I enjoy it
[Music]
Rapha compares me compasses to possibly
oh my gosh well grandma's got muscle
[Music]
it's the local at the corridor soon
amenities whom do you is just confused
yeah cuz he's [ __ ] dead don't let her
bite her
okay
[Music]
hey we need to go we need to get her to
the hospital
Gabrielle where's your sister a potato
boy where is he
geez
where the [ __ ] are the keys Zig dad's
car keys are on the dash no one cared
that grandpa came back alive my mom get
the kids meet at the hospital
don't take the highway he's blocked he
might want to walk
I'll bring the van around here's more
from the Stossel Rihanna we have to go
Gaga's hurt come on honey we have to go
County General Hospital I know the way
[Music]
seemed like to try and do like lots of
us you know when it started up oh he got
a scratch too huh oh [ __ ] boy you Dan
it's like he knows
Oh
[Music]
it's just herps okay calm down it's very
nice I get stressed out okay
Hey look at stack septic a yeah I take
every chance that I came gay tell me
when it reaches the campfire
who the [ __ ] are these people maybe we
should go I've never seen so many why
does that matter
I don't think I've seen this many it's
definitely growing yeah I miss the
soundtrack insane
is that a ghost one what the [ __ ] is
that my water book [ __ ] is that wine or
just got there
did you say that in four hours
come on I can point we should keep
moving all kids are asleep yeah
listen before you judgment can I be a
hipster okay Jesus Christ
right in the moment the hurt is speeding
up a little I thought it was drifting
Southwest but I'm not sure anymore
every time I think we should just bed
down somewhere and wait for it to pass I
can't shake the thought of us getting
caught in the middle of it it just keeps
coming it's slow but that almost makes
it worse it'd definitely be nice to stop
car crash and three we've been on the
move you know what I don't know it feels
risky not if we find somewhere secure
we'll figure it out we always do
Hey alright trigger there's a hula Carla
did you see any of you found weed are
you kidding people were probably growing
this before they realized they needed
food
should we be smoking now should be
smoking now yeah it seems like a bad
idea
relax Marianas got headphones on and
Gabe is drooling I think we're in the
clear
you want some yeah okay sure
we are setting an awesome example there
asleep oh when I found out David had
kids I told him I am not changing Who I
am err on them and when he proposed I
reminded him that I'm not exactly
stepmother material he's some point it
was reassuring but yeah I could tell he
was worried about it
I knew he tried to get me to change or
at least you'd hope that bigger other
kids more what changed me you know and
he was stubborn
he was always stubborn like that even
when we were kids he saw the world in a
certain way and he'd try and make you
see that way too
so that's where Gabe gets it from I used
to talk [ __ ] about all those mothers
who'd go on about raising their kids
being the hardest thing in the world
it's making me start to think they had a
point his mood swings are just I don't
know some days I just look at my mobile
our girls sat around joking
you're gonna be a doctor Jesus it's
gonna be on Gawker
you really shouldn't say things like
that I said it was a joke it's half a
joke it's all joke look I love these
kids but I could do without Gabe
reminding me I'm not his mother whenever
he's pissed you're not my mother her
puberty hormones
oh yeah the second you start getting
boners the whole world starts to get
dark
what that [ __ ] is that quote are you
talking yeah sounds delightful compared
to dealing with bloody underwear Christ
I need to get laid wait what happened to
walking dead we're talking about boners
and period right now what the [ __ ] is
this where is Clementine there's been 18
minutes and I have yet to see claiming
clip alright wanna pull over I realized
that was an awkward transition sorry
about that now I can pull over I
wouldn't take a minute wouldn't be worth
it for just a minute huh don't worry
baby
I just need 15 seconds oh [ __ ] ten
[ __ ] I'll take five uh where's the
milk and we'd go back to sleep we had a
sky hey Mariano I am Mariana I think we
are must date a skunk or something back
there I already know you guys do drugs
that's a pretty severe way of phrasing
it Mariana don't tell Gabe he's the one
who told me Oh
god you're even smoking in the car now
all right everyone roll the windows down
before you all get contact hi we're
about to make a supply stop
I want to know how many days after the
outbreak this is hey I got an
achievement Wow
that feels great thank you again
is it one I want and you actually care
about achievements like I could not give
her that [ __ ] oh nice
wouldn't be a Walking Dead game without
a little bit of walking this
someone needs to do better quality
control and just like just play through
it slowly and be like Oh something
happened there like I do it with my
videos all the time just to make sure
like it's so easy when you make cuts and
stuff I'm not saying it's the same thing
but still it kind of takes away the
immersion a little bit when you see a
weird movement with their bodies that
isn't supposed to be there all right
well maybe I'll get to use this pretty
soon I'm sure pretty soon
oh it switched to my keyboard great you
want a moment alone Mari [ __ ] why did he
do I'm praying I find a candy bar all
right what do we actually need was that
a joke a candy bar need Mariana not want
uh water bottle we're gonna do bottle
flips well let's start with some gas and
move up from there oh no it's jack Oh
[Music]
you look nice and here he comes oh I see
this is the guy and from the beginning
I'm so stupid where are you going did
that click oh you'll have fun oh man I
feel stupid Jesus it never ends with him
of course it's Hammonds I hate when they
fight like that I really hate it it's
like a hoe Gabe wants to do is argue
doesn't matter what it's about hey I
know that's what families do oh and
that's the daughter oh my god I come and
I fight all over again at least you have
your headphones
the batteries have been dead for a
couple of weeks I mostly wear them to
fool you guys it's easier to stay out of
it that way well when you put it that
way I wish I had a pair too you can
borrow mine if you want
No I might just have to do that terrible
I did a junkyard you never know these
past four years people have been
hoarding all kind of [ __ ] in all kinds
of places
oh and Mari if there's any trouble you
find one of these cars yeah lock
yourself in and don't come out not even
once it's quiet and wait as long as you
can okay good girl
tell me honestly did that click for you
before it did for me I'm sorry if I'm
stupid okay hey I didn't think about it
so weird the guy from the beginning
potential Clementine boyfriend material
which is why I'm excited this is cool I
get to walk with my flashlight hey there
so we got marijuana and my name is
something else I don't remember
and we're looking for a Baroness look at
the barrels okay he's walking over
that's pretty cool I can dig it waste
oil only used to us how do you know the
difference just by looking at them
was that a panties flying around did you
see that
hold RIT to walk faster maybe you can
siphon the gas from this car empty I
wouldn't have minded having one of these
back in the day I don't care about what
you think about scythe siphon how do i
okay so siphon we we hit it and then we
this one looks promising
okay well let's how about hey I got a
crazy idea
how about weed scythe scythe onions
that's a weird word to say siphon scythe
sighs shut up
bingo Bain badda-boom badda-bing why am
I doing this I don't know all i care
about is clementine does this game not
realize that yeah I don't think these
tires would fit the van okay how about
we climb up this ladder that seems like
a good idea
so one that one part of a sketch here
spoilers
it's going to be walking dead I'm very
excited it's probably one of my favorite
a song not enough Gabe hey Gabe let's go
take a look over there yeah let's stick
together babe stay close to javi got it
thank you
alright that seems like the right thing
to do here
[Music]
Hey look there's one they never took two
pieces good catch
I did something literally me something
that Brawley would have seen anyway [ __ ]
it's locked
maybe we can find some medicine inside
all right here goes nothing
they change the controls and stuff like
that it's a big week [ __ ] yeah yeah is
that all he contributes [ __ ] smiling
getting the [ __ ] out away from my sight
zombie apocalypse look at all that fuel
you take a while I mean it's kind of a
tiny all right whatever so why don't we
enjoy yourself a little bit
okay well let's check here locked now
well at least it had some gas you can
break the window you have a crowbar no
oh no oh oh he's bald oh god I hate bald
people
no offense of all people I don't hate
you but I hate why that's why eyeballs
people get some hair looks like it came
from in there
looks like we shouldn't go there Gabe
stay close
Gabe give him give him your beanie fast
uh-oh I don't like this
[ __ ] was that sound alright I suppose we
should go in here alright Gabe what are
you doing we can back out or we can look
in let's be careful in him might be able
to get in through the hatch okay and why
why did we want to get in through the
hatch Kevin let's back out
move this ooh
secret entry I like you hey Gabe why
don't you help instead of looking the
side cards here we go
why does Gabe have a gun and not me [ __ ]
I'd be terrified I would look behind
right away
Gabe come check this out I wouldn't be
yelling either sorry I'm just thinking
if this is me okay no that's not the
cleanest place on the muertos at least
no dead ones at least
that's right just be careful and some of
their languages I understand Russian wow
this place is decked out yeah they got
pickles look at this place
avocado Wow
one of you started looting men
hey batteries
[Music]
that's cool
yeah dip sauce are you kidding me
lucky for you they put enough
preservatives and this stuff to last for
centuries there's enough food in here to
keep us going for a long time look at
this shadow there in the grand Lance
shadow from the pudding walking do you
want me to play test your games this is
actual honest-to-god pudding seriously
it's not just food there's a mattress
there's blankets someone else's mattress
someone else's blankets we need to don't
care take our gas don't get on the road
well you gotta admit it's kind of cozy
in here
the van is cozy this is creepy come on
one night we bunk down you know real
meal it would be nice not to sleep in
the van for a change please the hurt is
coming if it's not here already we
should go and get ahead of it before
it's too late
the fence is reinforced we'll be fine we
found this why can't we just enjoy it I
think we should keep moving actually if
there's a child sleep well for one Shh
come on no it's not a big deal shut the
[ __ ] up I'm trying to think here you've
got guns we can protect ourselves that's
a terrible idea and you're a kid so shut
the [ __ ] up so much better after some
real sleep we're gonna get what we came
for and get out of here great another
shitty cramped night in our shitty
cramped van hurry come on
these are hurt and coming after us I
want to keep moving okay I don't care if
it's uncomfortable
[Music]
but I want to sex tonight if you know
what I mean
pound it I am so sorry what is okay hey
I got batteries Oh guess one
now you can really drown us out I
wouldn't normally give it to her but
since we had to be kind of a dick you
know we I figured I can give him to her
you know I have nice qualities too
believe it or not thank you very much
thanks for that hey you're welcome that
can be up and all how does it feel to be
the bad guy this time it must be a new
sensation for you oh boy sleeping in the
van again cause you definitely owe me
one
yeah well you owe me like a dozen so
I'll just shave it off your tab hey Kate
can you come help us with this damn it
[Music]
hey wait but you Oh
this way you can make up for being the
bad guy
Thanks grab some gas we need to head out
soon well I'm already grabbing it and
later I'm plan to grab some ass I'm top
not just yes you got it
what the [ __ ] do you think you're doing
with our gas I don't know where was
yours okay everyone come on speak up
whoa whoa the gas is all there
just keep it yeah I'm thinking it's a
little too late for that
yank the loan or typing I can tell I
know you got people I'm alone I'm alone
honestly people just swore me down
uh-huh all alone yeah sure you are fan
out look for the others
Lonnie you're with me time to kill some
people
sorry Lonnie but you're gonna be Bonnie
I mean by it fine
goodbye knee day you [ __ ] in there
I got your bar you don't want to get in
shot you best come out there careful
with your hands up go on
you first you get ambushed by her own
people that shit's gonna make my day
open it real slowly
[ __ ] what did we do don't [ __ ] around
with me boy what do we do I don't know
we gonna [ __ ] around we're gonna [ __ ]
around real good can take off that
stupid hat are you fake hipster
okay yeah that's right slide that [ __ ] I
knew you weren't alone
[ __ ] I knew it I know that's awesome
now how come these are all open I [ __ ]
love playing it just take what you like
but we hardly took any really someone
must have been here before us I just
said we we you just said we you blind
sack of [ __ ] you told me you were alone
look I I get it alright you're starving
who the [ __ ] is it at the end of your
rope thought you hit pay dirt honest
mistake
but I got this sneaky [ __ ] feelin how
that you're full of [ __ ]
I ain't gonna let it be like last time
some [ __ ] rolled on us keep an eye
on this [ __ ] I want to grab some
cuffs you got it no just chill okay
Aulani
no need to make this any harder Lonnie
your dad's your buddy's not thinking
straight so let's talk okay you and me
we can get this sorted out
no it's his call this doesn't have to go
the [ __ ] was that noise that was that
reckless go hide over there boys
it's my pet raccoon Steve please don't
hurt Steve if you know something you
better spill it
you don't want me finding out for myself
come on man what else I'm we're toast
down there we're a bunch of them outside
to the dead huh well then we better take
care of that shouldn't we I don't want
to kill Lonnie Lonnie is my favorite
character so far he's so awesome
hi but I'm on it okay you did it anyway
see I didn't do you guys do the [ __ ] in
there I'm sorry Lonnie I love you
no [ __ ] all right mr. hipster boy oh
god he's about [ __ ] he's got a shouting
hey I didn't kill Lonnie Lonnie kill him
suffer you have to pay for what you do
wait don't oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] I that back [ __ ] in here we
are sleeping in the van no we're not we
got hit in the head by other people how
they got one of those zip ties Thanks
hey my family where are they what did
you do with my family please say
something please man just do us both a
favor and pretend you're still asleep I
wouldn't start talking if I were you
you're lucky we'd do things a certain
way I'm already tempted to put a bullet
in your brain for what you did to Lonnie
back there dude I fell tariffs talk
about angry there's got to be a way we
can work all this out just knock me a
deal or something
it ain't my call all right you best be
glad it ain't
please just stop all right you don't
want me riled up kid
not another word or god help me I'll put
you to sleep myself
we still got a haul ahead of us and I'm
not about to listen
whoa
Pam that was louder
that was very [ __ ] loud hey look at
that it's a gun well I better I'd be
ashamed if oh no I have the gun now
oh that's too bad why did the tree fall
what are the [ __ ] odds Hey
hey [ __ ] let him go
what should I do oh [ __ ] me dude I'm a
good shot how about that oh [ __ ] why did
I shoot him now I feel terrible yeah
well at least it wasn't Lonny
that's good just keep looking forward oh
I recognize that voice
look I'm no threat to you okay I
surrender I know that voice
no threat huh tell that to the dead guy
oh my god she's so pretty
no don't do anything stupid cuz I'll
shoot a lot quicker than you did oh my
god
she's a badass she's got a [ __ ] spaz
no she's not a kid she's funny bear wait
did you do that oh my god okay alright
we're gonna end that episode there Chris
oh boy that was exciting
um okay now I realize I couldn't make
this episode alo longer but I want to
keep it kind of like a daily series cuz
I think that's a really fun way to watch
well let me know if you want want to see
more or less or whatever I do value your
opinion because you were doing this
together and yeah I'll see you tomorrow
with a new episode this is so exciting
oh my god clemmy's back yes guys back
thank you for watching I'll see you
tomorrow as always stay awesome brush